continue to test everybody welcome to on
the book video I'm going to be a little
quieter today because I'm recording this
on a Friday evening 1030 at night Hayden
is in that room over there sleeping
luckily he's a deep sleeper and
hopefully I don't get too overexcited on
this one I want to talk about testing
and I've talked about before on the
channel and I think entrepreneurs don't
do enough tests I think it's important
to test your assumptions you test the
big ideas test the small ideas I think
the difference between a lot of
stressful entrepreneurs and ones that
don't quite make it our judge by the
number of tests that you run and you
want to be constantly running multiple
tasks on your business to find the
ultimate performance to help you create
the product or service that you really
will hit the market strong so how's
release in my book is I'm working on
coming up with the subtitles and I came
up with the subtitle for my book in my
publisher and my agent didn't like my
subtitle so they both came up with a
subtitle that they thought would be
appropriate that I didn't like sin I can
about the variation and then I gave it
to my team and they came up with two
variations as well so now we have six
variations of a potential sub title for
the book and it may seem like a small
thing like who cares it's just a
subtitle but attention to the details
makes a difference and I am so all in on
this book that I'm paying attention to
all these little minor things because it
means something to me and I want to pay
attention to them and so we've got these
six title options now and I convinced my
publisher to let me share it with the 30
people who test rode the book and gave
me feedback and we're going to see who
wins we're going to see who has the best
one we're gonna see what the audience
thinks right we're going to see what the
people will end up buying the book think
and I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure that
my publisher one and my agent one are
not going to win I just feel like
they're not going to win I like the ones
at my team front with two and I like the
ones that my both of my version so we'll
see how it goes and that will help guide
the decision as to what the final
subtitle works out to be and I think
what's really important to understand as
entrepreneurs is
you will be successful you will make
money you will have an impact you will
get reach when you can combine doing
something that you love with something
that adds a lot of value to people's
lives do what you love and be passionate
about and stick to it and have your
vision say you like this is where I want
to go but not be so attached to the how
right I want to write this book there's
a ton of great information in the book
it's going to help a lot of
entrepreneurs I think is going to shake
the foundation of a lot of entrepreneurs
I'm really excited but the specifics of
the subtitle you know I'm not so
attached it has to be exactly this
subtitle or it's not going to work and
so that's where tweaks around what the
market is interested in is helpful right
so i can combine my big picture where i
want to take this with the small picture
tactical execution to make that happen
based on market feedback is super
important to have both if you want to
create a product or service that has a
lot of reach and has a lot of potential
so I encourage you to increase the
number of tests that you do increase the
number of experiments small experiments
like be testing at least a new thing
every week in some area of your business
or some curiosity that you want to touch
and explore and learn a little bit more
about stop having i'll get to that one
day stop having bucket lists stop having
plans for where you're going to be in
five years or ten years right start
taking action on it right now and often
you'll find that those five ten year
planes are either one like not what you
want to do it all and so that's great
for you to find it out sooner and two
they don't have to be that far away like
it doesn't have to be something that
takes you that long you can condense
something from five years down to six
months or three months sometimes or week
sometimes just by getting out and doing
it and taking action so increase the
number of experiments increase the
number of tests in your business and you
will dramatically increase the success
of your company all right let's get to
the questions super excited love the
questions first one comes in jones
crimson what tips do you have for
avoiding theft my first book was what i
thought would be my life's work when I
was young and I didn't want to risk
someone stealing our Magnus opus so to
speak I don't know what the fear is
around theft I don't know if you're
working with a publisher or you're just
trying to do it on your own I think when
you're working with the public
sure you sign off the rights right so
for me I don't own the rights to my book
I own the YouTube rights hang on a bunch
of other rights but I don't own the
rights to the book so they will own the
book and I get payment for it I got an
upfront payment and they get royalty
payments for it so when you deal with a
publisher I don't know what the big
concern is because you're gonna they're
going to own it at the end of the day if
you're doing self-publishing I don't
know I don't know what the the laws are
around that like if you publish a book
and then somebody else comes and takes
it word for word and publishes it
themselves I'm assuming there's some
copyright laws around that but you want
to talk to a lawyer about it the
legalities around that are pretty new to
me and I'm really only familiar with the
with the published route from a legal
point of view I don't pretend to be a
lawyer I don't act like a lawyer on TV
and I just speak of what I know so I
mean end of the day if you really
worried about it go talk to a lawyer go
get their feedback see what they think
and take it from there 10 more weeks
superfan love you tame kind of rhyme
superfan love you tame that was a fun
video to watch love see Nina and Hayden
you to always make me smile thank me
smile too tame I like hearing how you
hire people and how you explain working
for a company to get experience and when
they aren't teaching you anything you go
full time into your business so what
happened with the logo on page 43 of
your book okay a while ago I talked
about the logos being cut out of a out
of my book they didn't want to have
pictures at all in the book and I'm
fighting for some of them at the end of
the day I didn't really care so much
about the logos one page in the book
talks about I'm giving a little bit of
secret away one page in book comes and
talks about helping you create a logo
for your company and what I love doing
is well in success and I talk about the
stories behind some iconic logos and
give you lessons on how you can learn
from them to apply it to your business
and your logo creation and having a logo
that has something that's powerful and
meaning meaningful to you they didn't
want to have pictures in the book and
they didn't want to deal with the rights
issues if you included logos from
certain brands and for me it wasn't it
wasn't a battle worth fighting you know
there are three things that I am
insanely adamant about that I am
fighting
every day on to make sure gets happy you
know gets included in the book because
it means a lot to me and you know logos
on page 43 I don't really care that much
the solution is going to be I'm going to
put it off on my website and we'll put a
link from the book to the website so the
content still going to be there they
actually wanted to cut the logo page
from the book which was not cool because
i love that page the test audience loved
that page and back to the topic of
testing because the test audience loved
that page i had data to show the
publishers like we cannot cut this page
people love it there's a lot of great
value on here we got to keep it in and
so the compromise was take out the
pictures put it on your website but keep
the written content which you know it's
a bit of a bummer but it's not a huge
deal I was just honestly when I was
ranting about that just tired of the BS
excuses right like that's not the real
reason why you don't want to like
nobody's going to not buy the book
because it's a logo on page 43 right so
that was why I upsets that because that
was the excuse I was given and is always
a real reason behind the excuse came
jones can't wait for your book man very
excited think you came I'm excited too
Amanda I think people sometimes hidden
run because they don't have a support
system can you address how to
self-motivate from within and how to
finish what you started on your own
belief Cheers that's the super tough
questions I think it's hard to be
motivated as an entrepreneur all the
time I think we look at stories of
successful entrepreneurs and we want to
be like those people and we don't
realize how hard it really really really
is until you actually get into starting
the business I think most important is
that you are insanely in love with what
you do you know I do this because I love
doing this is a Friday night 1030 you
know what are you doing on 1030 and
Friday night I'm making videos for my
youtube channel you know like i love
this i love the process not just the
outcome I love helping people I love
answering your questions and when you
love what you do and you can get lost in
it you know when your work can make you
feel happy when when you're depressed to
things and you can bury yourself in your
creations in your art and that makes you
come alive that's the power
thing and and if you don't love what you
do then you will quit you will give up
once it gets hard you have to be crazy
in love with what you're doing to want
to keep going I feel like I should be
yelling my way through this but I'm
concerned about Hayden waking up the
second thing is having having some kind
of support system and I really you know
when you say support system I really
lump that in their environment so it's
great to have friends who support you if
not then go find a mastermind group what
videos do you watch in the morning to
give you ideas and keep you motivated I
used to watch I used to read a page from
a book every morning that had stories of
famous entrepreneurs and and just
reading their stories made me feel like
you know these guys can do it so I can
do it and it also gave me so give me the
motivation but it also give me some
strategies of what I could do to grow my
company I wanted to make that video so
that's why I have the interests of
series in a top 10 series and the the
leaders that I'm training I'm part of
the leadership training for them is you
need to watch the top 10 videos every
day like you need to surround yourself
with greatness you need to be around
these great people even if you've never
meet them ever in your life you need to
learn from them to help push you beyond
your comfort zone and help keep you
motivated to go off and do something
great so I think those two things really
help find something that you love so
insanely much that you want to do it
every day you would do it if you weren't
getting paid because you won't get paid
at the start for a while and to create
that environment that fosters you to
want to go out and do great things every
day Alex I believe he's inspired
everyone in your orbit you're destined
for greatness I need you by my side for
my 20-year dream thankfully mr. Zack I'm
already here bro I'm already here I'm
answering your questions I'm making
videos I'm by your side let's do it next
20 years Olaf is it only me each time
you talk about your editor agency I get
the impression you regret having chosen
and for your big project that's the
interesting question thank you Olaf I
think when I when I make these videos
that it can often turn into a rant
session there are definitely a lot of
frustrating parts of dealing with a
publisher and dealing with in in in
agent
an editor I'm facing most of that right
now I don't regret it though I don't
want to self publish this book I'm I
believe that the publisher that I'm with
the options that we had is the is the
best one to go with I think like in any
relationship there are times they get
tough right if you have a partnership if
you have you know a spouse or a
girlfriend there's going to be times
where it gets really tough and I think
when you come from different places it
makes it even harder you know I want to
create something that will be great I
want to create something that will make
history I want to create something that
people will proudly put on their
bookshelf will read every single year as
a refresher will give to their parents
because it had such an impact on them
that's what I want to create you know I
get frustrated when I'm working with
people who don't share that same vision
who wanted you know they'll say they
want to create something great but they
don't actually believe it and just the
standards aren't as high as my my
standards I guess the video becomes a
place to vent for me and I will vent you
know internally also about entrepreneurs
I'm working with our people on my team
if they're not getting to the place
where I want them to be I you know I
either need to ship their mindset or
it's on me to to make myself work harder
to get them to where I know they can be
you know there's nothing more
frustrating if you look at you know
believe is my one word there's nothing
more frustrating than believing somebody
can be somewhere and they don't see it
in themselves and they're reluctant to
want to take the steps to get there
where it's so clear for you or they
could be but I don't regret making
decision at all a hundred percent no
regret I think I made the right decision
super excited and happy about it these
are just some of the roadblocks that you
face as you build the business and as
you write a book and the idea of making
this series was to show people kind of
behind the scenes of what goes on from
an author's perspective maybe they if
they made their own video to be like
Ivan making us do these things he
doesn't understand the publishing
industry you know maybe they I'm sure
they have their own vents
frustrations with me but I don't think
they regret making a decision to work
with me either so yeah I thank you for
allowing me to expand on that because
it's definitely something that I I am
extremely grateful for and extremely
excited about even though I event and I
vent to try to encourage you guys right
to when you're faced with these things
in your life when people give you BS
answers or people don't have high
standards over people don't see your
vision to do something about it to stand
up right I stand up I take a stand on
things that I want to see happen and I
will pull people kicking and screaming
with me to go achieve my vision if need
be or i'll be an army of one and just
make it happen and so that's the point
of kind of getting passionate excited
because it's not just a frustration I'm
feeling I feel it on behalf of you guys
and I feel like you're going through
some of these same things and you may
not have anybody kind of helping you
along on that path and I want to turn up
to help you stand up for yourself so
that's where the the passion and
excitement comes from because I want to
see you guys build something special
okay next visionary just a question that
has been stuck in my mind should you
pursue what you love to do or pursue
something that helps people I guess what
I'm saying is be you or be the hero I my
answer there is easy be both like that's
where the geniuses embrace the end we
have a whole series on the end the
greatest opportunity for you and I
talked about earlier or even on this
episode is the intersection of what you
love doing with what helps people often
what you have to do is you know what you
love doing is the big picture is the
vision you know this is where you wanna
the kind of company want to build is the
impact you want to have and then how you
help people can can change and often
needs to change often solving a problem
for yourself there's a lot of people who
have the same problem and you can help
them too but you may need to tweak it a
little bit you may need to make some
market adjustments but be yourself and
be the hero right like those are not
opposites in my mind you are the hero
you are the best hero when you're being
yourself and you're being true to what
you're passionate
I don't think you are really a hero if
you're doing things that you're not
excited about you can rise a little bit
you can like chase an opportunity that
will last for a little bit of time but
if you want long lasting mega impactful
success it's going to come only when you
absolutely love what you do and you're
providing value and when you figure that
out that intersection that's the big
time baby next Youssef the audio is
stuttering can you please kindly
reuploaded yeah I hear you guys a lot of
you I no use of thank you and Michael
wrote in a couple of you guys wrote in
about the audio I I usually record these
with blab recently and lavish has been
causing some issues I didn't notice
until i was already done there was a
second timer recorded the first time it
lost my recording completely Christina
my video editor kindly asked me not to
record on blab this week but to record
use my camera so here we are Zeno you
may not like it but at times I'd like to
see you being upset that's when you show
your heart and passion even more than
usually it's interesting cuz I'm not
really an upset guy that much I feel
like I get upset on behalf of others
more than I'll get upset for myself and
I think a lot of that is reflected in
these videos when I when I turn up about
something it's because I don't want to
see the people watching you guys I don't
want to see you guys make mistakes a lot
of what I talk about is from mistakes
that I made and I don't regret mistakes
that I made because I feel like they got
me to where I am now but if I can help
you guys not make the same mistakes and
learn from success and learn from
failure and get there faster that's
awesome for me and quite often to do
that you need to turn up at least for me
my style is more to turn up than to like
be calm and sedated I'm not necessarily
like the Zen master quiet you know
wisdom guy I like passion passion is my
fire passion is my secret weapon and but
i think really kind of digging deeper
and understanding that is more for you
guys you know I care a lot about you
being successful and
you making a change in your life and the
best way that I male able to do that to
express that is to is to turn up and in
and get upset but this is a different
vibe today because Hayden's asleep and
so we're chillin together for me on a
Friday night next question and make uh
what would you say about a boss that
that doesn't give a damn about your best
I say you need a new boss I say you need
a new boss if you have a boss who
doesn't care about you who doesn't care
about your best isn't care about your
growth doesn't care development doesn't
look for opportunities for you doesn't
set you up for success that's a bad boss
something that I'm going through helping
and mentoring an entrepreneur close to
me if you're working for a leader that
does not really see you as someone
important that does not try to train you
and educate you and make you the best
version of yourself and try to see you
as someone greater than yourself right
like you have a limit of you we all have
limit views of ourselves you want to be
around people who push you who see more
in you than you seen yourself who say I
think you could deliver that speech at
that event next month and you're sitting
there saying are you kidding me I don't
want to speak in front of people I've
never done that you know all these fears
that set in but the fact that somebody
else believes in you and is pushing you
to do that at least once at least a try
is something that you need in your life
like we need people to push us and if
you have a boss that doesn't care about
you and is not pushing you then go find
a new boss or be your own boss like
there's tons of bosses the reason to
take a job is to learn the reason to
have a boss is to learn so if you're not
learning go find a new boss immediately
because you don't need to wake up and
drive to another job that you hate for
another day go find a job where you're
going to learn something eat cookie hey
Evan I'm as motivated internally as I am
externally but I'm having a hard time
keeping my work at the consistent could
you help me with some advice on how not
to slip back into the dark side that's
an interesting one for me I divide my
work in the kind of two chunks I think
one is super important to have a
schedule and have days to do different
things so for me I record most of my
videos on a Wednesday as an example on
thursdays until my public
facing days to do my hanging out to do
my calls into my meetings on tuesday i
doing book related stuff you know every
day of the week has its own thing and
its own time slot and so it helps keep
me productive and make sure that i'm
doing the things that i need to do that
being said so like the schedule super
important but that being said you can
only force yourself to do something that
you don't enjoy for so long you know you
can only force yourself to stick to a
diet that you know you don't really like
for so long you know you can only drink
water and tea for so long right like you
can only do work that you hate and force
yourself for so long before you'll break
it and want to go do something else and
so if you're constantly struggling with
this yes the schedule may help and this
is what people's people do the default
to schedule the default the tools like
what tools can I use to keep me more you
know efficient you know or keep me back
on track and they download a thousand
different apps and to-do list kind of
tools and I tried outlook and gmail and
my calendar and all these different
things in Evernote and CRMs and like
nothing's working and they want the next
tool and really the reality for those
people if that's you is that the tool
will not save you it's that your work is
boring the stuff you're doing is just
not exciting to you you know there are
days when you are working something that
you're excited that you can just get
lost in right like you start you wake up
you're so excited like maybe you wake up
early because you were so excited
thinking about it and then you're
working the whole day and you look up
but it's like six o'clock at night like
what happened where did the day go and
you just want to keep on working where
you can just get lost not because you're
being forced to do it by a deadline or
customer or something but like you just
love what you're doing you love the
creation of what you're doing you want
to try to do that as much as possible
and I'm not every day is going to be
amazing and not every day you're going
to get lost in your work and I get that
but if you're doing work that you hate
and you need to constantly motivate
yourself to do then chances are you're
not doing a lot of the work that you
should be doing your work is just too
boring and so if that's you every day
you could try the tools but stop blaming
the tools if this is constantly
happening to you you
just doing stuff that you're not excited
by so change it immediately last
question from Doug really looking
forward to this when are you going to
reveal the name of the book if you
haven't already I haven't yet I have to
talk to my publisher to see what did
what the deal is about that most authors
when they're creating a book don't do
this behind-the-scenes kind of stuff and
share a lot before it comes out so we're
looking at a December 6 release i
believe and so I don't know when I'm
supposed to when I'm able to be able to
tell the book and do some pre marketing
my head is almost in the marketing side
right now we're just finishing up as i
said the the test in the titles people
signing off on everything the
proofreading editing all of that stuff
that i'm not super excited about the
kind of boring stuff for me but it has
to get done and then once that's down
going into marketing mode and so i'll be
able to answer all your marketing
questions and release the book title and
what it's all about and I'm so itchy to
get into that phase right now so itchy
so as soon as as soon as kind of we've
signed off on that I'm gonna have a
conversation with publisher let them
know hey the people want to know the
people want to know what this books
about we're like how many how many weeks
in 40-something weeks in a video and we
still don't know what the title is or
the topic of the book so thank you guys
your patience it's coming soon I promise
and as soon as I'm able to i will let
you know so it's awesome thank you guys
for all the questions i'd love to know
your thoughts on the topic at the top
which was about testing are you running
enough tests what are the tests you're
running right now how can you run a new
test every single week for your business
if you need help come with the test
ideas leave in the comments and believe
nation will step up and give you some
ideas i'd also if you have questions
about my book the book writing process
anything book-related leave it below and
i'll answer next week's video thank you
guys so much for watching I know it's
coming on Monday but for me it's Friday
so I hope you have had a great weekend
then and have a great week ahead
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon